and so if I'm going to make a decision
what to do with your friends that you
donated to leet I'm going to use it to
provide healthy nutritious food which is
more important to give to the poor we we
therefore focus our energies on two
areas first how we started which was
cooked meals and there we work very very
closely with corporate cafeterias event
halls hotels the Israeli Army to make
sure that excess meals not that we're on
people's tables that excess meals that
maybe were in the buffet or even better
were never served at all will be picked
up primarily by our drivers in
refrigerated trucks and sometimes by
Volunteers in their own
cars welcome to 20-minute leaders just
sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started 20-minute leaders is a proud
supporter of makeawish Israel and Tech
to piece and is in proud collaboration
with secret cord Ventures J Ventures
Riverside FM Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with
ctec hello and welcome to 20-minute
leaders this episode is about a very
special organization that is helping
lots of people and a very special leader
who runs this organization for many
years meet Joseph gitler the chairman of
leet Israel Joseph formed leet Israel in
2003 as a oneman food rescue project
which has since grown into the largest
food bank and leading food rescue
operation in Israel Le at Israel
provides food and nutritional support to
get this more than
223,000 needy Israelis weekly through
its partnership with 260 nonprofit
organizations serving the
poor Joseph gitler welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for being here
how are you I'm great thank you for the
opportunity thank you so much for being
here Joseph your work um being the
chairman of leet Israel for almost the
last 20 years I'm so excited to hear
about you know leet the journey and you
know what what you're doing there to
help nonprofit organizations in Israel
and the the the largest not food
nonprofit organization in Israel looking
at food scarcity looking at different
solutions in the Israeli ecosystem for
for food you know even before we dive
into Le tell me a little bit about
yourself your your upbringing and what
leads you to to do this incredible thing
sure okay so I grew up in New York till
the age of 15 then we went just a little
bit over the George Washington Bridge
continued in t New Jersey then I got
married to my wife Leela who's from
Toronto originally and went back over
the George Washington bridge and lived
in Riverdale New York uh I was brought
up with the ideal of moving to Israel
which many let's say modern Orthodox
Jews in America are brought up that way
but very few actually take the plunge
and move to Israel my late father used
to say to me that of all things is what
you're going to listen to but that's
what happened we decided we wanted to go
and so we've been living here in Israel
for the last 22 years um very happily uh
we don't regret our decision I would say
it's certainly from my point of view and
I would say my wife also based on her
career choices is dramatically different
than I think what we would be doing if
we stayed in North America I'm sure I'm
sure and your passion for for food
nonprofit impact where where does that
stem from so I don't I don't know if I
have a passion for food but I have a
passion for not wasting food okay I like
a good meal like anyone else
uh I appreciate good food I understand
the social aspects I like the social
aspects of sitting and eating food with
friends and family um but I'm not a
foodie in that sense I'm fortunate that
I'm very spoiled I don't help much in
the kitchen and I have a fantastically
amazing Chef in my house my wife so um
so I eat well also um look I think for
me it was just coming to Israel with
certain expectations
um yes I came in 99 it was the height of
the first tech broom in Israel right
we've been through at least another one
or two cycles since then we hope it'll
we hope it'll this one will survive
better than the last two did but coming
here with certain
expectations and what I expected from
the
country and uh you know sadly I learned
that Israel is very s very similar to
other countries you know we can call
ourselves startup nation which we may be
and we have wonderful things going on
here in the economy but unfortunately uh
with all that Brilliance we haven't
figured out how not to leave behind 15
or 20% of the population who are
struggling to make ends meet so really
in my life I was working here uh we we
our family has a software business here
and I was working and I just B the you
know the Rand of milk and honey on the
one hand and the amount of and the
quality of the food and it's only gotten
better since I moved here and on the
other hand the people struggling to make
ends meet in a country you know getting
richer by the day and that's such a
painful thing nothing's more painful
well starvation is more painful and
thankfully we don't have that in Israel
but a very painful way to live life is
always seeing you what others have that
you consider basic necessities and you
struggling to get those and so my
decision a little over 19 years ago was
try to put those two together make sure
all this excess food in the land of milk
and honey wasn't going to waste and
making sure it got to those people who
are struggling to C to keep up with
startup nation and all the expense that
that's brought to our country wow and so
tell me a little bit about what you've
observed about the Latin the ecosystem
and the opportunity that you saw with
the formation of leet Israel or
previously table to table right so I so
okay so ecosystems that you know that's
a real Tech kind of word but if I think
about the ecosystem we're in if I think
about volunteerism I think
about I think about government support
government
regulation I think about corporate
support you know it a lot of things are
not different than business per se Tech
also is concerned with government
regulation but from a different aspect
that I am unless you're if you're a food
Tech then you have similar concerns to
concerns I have about you know producing
and moving food as an example but you
know the ecosystem is the third sector
in Israel it's a very large sector no
different than the United States 152% of
the economy is in the third sector
you're talking billions and billions and
billions of shekels a year hundreds of
thousands of Israelis who live in this
sector you know it's a sector that
sometimes gets a negative wrap meaning
people who work in that sector do that
because they couldn't work elsewhere
which is of course I've seen over the
last 20 years Preposterous there are
people who've made it in the for-profit
sector who then decide to bring their
skills to the nonprofit sector but there
are also many talented people who make a
decision to work in the third sector
which frankly is trying to solve the
world's most difficult problems but with
a lot of limitations most
importantly limitations on how much they
can get paid
right imagine if you that to the
high-tech sector what what what kind of
quality of employees you would get and
so you know so that's one aspect of the
ecosystem and it's a big ecosystem and
the other I would really say is I think
about volunteerism and that's where we
differentiate uh likely from a lot of
the other guests you have on this show
and that is the nonprofit world gets a
lot of things for free okay so the luet
has 30 to 40,000 volunteers every year
helping us wow
vegetables in the fields helping us
repack for fruits and vegetables for
ultimate delivery to the 250 agencies we
serve that's just uh that's one big
difference and a big piece of the
ecosystem the other one and I'll take a
g a term from the tech World stealth
mode okay I don't think that's a term
that exists in the charity world right
the only thing about charity is not
sharing our financial donor lists very
appreciate stealth we don't want us
sharing their names and contact
information with other Charities but
everything else is a beautiful sharing
world where you Le is part of a
international ecosystem of food banks
who share with each other I'll give an
example we just had a Mission to Israel
and the global Food Bank Network which
we are the Israeli representative of
sent food Bankers from Kenya Ghana and
the Philippines to learn from see how we
do things and take some of that home
with them and we learn from them and we
learn from food banks throughout the
world and everyone shares their
information very readily which makes the
you know the word I
inhabit very pleasant in many ways
incredible so take tell me a little bit
about lead as an organization what what
does the model actually consist of okay
so lead is quite typical in its model
we're an umbrella
organization looking for sources of
healthy nutritious food that would go to
waste and distributing that to a network
of nonprofit organizations throughout
the state of Israel both Jewish and
non-jewish alike so the the uh builds
you know the the the umbrella aspect
that's quite typical if you take any
major food bank in the United States
that would be their structure as well um
the difference is what we do and how we
do it so leet happens to focus early
unhealthy food we don't have a problem
with unhealthy food and if we get all
the money in the world we would pick it
up but we don't and so if I'm going to
make a decision what to do with your
friends that you donated to leet I'm
going to use it to provide healthy
nutritious food which is more important
to give to the poor we we therefore
focus our energies on two areas first
how we started which was cooked meals
and there we work very very closely with
corporate cafeterias event halls Hots
the Israeli Army to make sure that
excess meals not that we're on people's
tables that excess meals that maybe were
in the buffet or even better were never
served at all will be picked up
primarily by our drivers and
refrigerated trucks and sometimes by
Volunteers in their own cars uh we will
probably rescue and distribute this year
about 2 to 2.2 million M wow and IS F
that simply would have gone in the
garbage it's great food and I I what I
really love most about that food is most
of that food goes directly to agencies
where it's eaten on the spot and it
takes the pressure off of them from
either having to cook or to raise the
money to buy food so if you take a
typical after school club for kids food
is important to them but it's not their
core Mission their core mission is
education and so they take the money
they might have for food they can buy
every kid their own laptop you know uh
pay for their driving lessons whatever
it be things that maybe we take for
granted um they can now provide to those
kids as well so that's side A of what we
do and the impact side B which is much
bigger and actually where our Hebrew
name leet comes from which is gleaning
in the fields ancient biblical precepts
um that's the we do with Farmers which
is you know the cooked food people
understand more there's always excess
you never know if going to make enough
we've all been through that in our own
homes fruits and vegetables is a
far as a percentage maybe smaller but in
bulk a far larger issue um in
Israel we estimate 3 to 400,000 tons of
fruits and vegetables goes to waste we
are breaking all our records this year
we're going to do 30,000 tons which is
the largest gleaning operation anywhere
in the World Imagine little Betty Israel
biggest operation of its sort part of
that is the weather the growing Cycles
the effectiveness of our Farmers all the
volunteer spirit I spoke about the
reasons which I think are most
interesting so it's market price
sometimes it doesn't make sense for the
farmer to pick it even after all their
hard work you have order cancellations
for example ret took in this year about
2500 extra tons of potatoes and carrots
that were destined for export to Russia
wow that's happening
so you have AXS of God ugly fruits and
vegetables if you've heard that term all
these things come together to create
Mass waste and again the waste is
massive but per individual farmer it
might only be 3 5 10% so when you come
to my Distribution Center last week you
would have seen a 100 cardboard boxes of
GRA
and to you and me that looks like huge
amounts but for your typical grape
farmer if it's 1% of their crop they're
doing great so it's a nice example of
everyone benefiting and of course for
leet getting high quality fruits and
vegetables to the poor is is a game Cher
for them and for their nutrition and
just for you know how they feel about
themselves wow so what do the logistics
of something like this look like I mean
that must be quite a handful so that's
essentially leet is a not for-profit
logistics company right to the benefit
of tens of thousands of volunteers but
in addition of our 120
employees
probably 90 of them are involved in
logistics either as truck
drivers uh forklift operators volunteer
coordinators food risers all working in
concert but yeah it is difficult I'll
I'll explain also why it's extremely
difficult even in relation to
corporations M you know a corporate
making yogurts they may get their um
estimates wrong on how much they're
going to sell but they know how much
they're going to produce or what they'd
like to produce let get after 19 years
of experience we have a good sense of
what's going to come in but not a
perfect sense and so that makes things
complicated for the agencies that we
serve you know what can they expect from
us it also makes things complicated for
our Logistics so you can imagine when
these 2500 extra tons came in uh that
were destined for Russia that added
hundreds of thousands of dollars to our
expenses unexpectedly it's a good
problem to have the difference is right
in the world if you're selling more you
have more income usually that's a
positive right unless you're selling
something below cost then it's a
negative sure the other you know we
expand where's the money coming from and
so that's you know often you hate to say
it but often in the nonprofit world the
biggest challenge especially when you
get to be big like us and well known and
I think well-run our biggest issue is
simply just resources you know we don't
have like in the again I yeah I'm not a
tech expert but you know if you go to
your world the startup world let's call
it okay um when you're successful
startup you raise money that gives you
runr maybe it's not enough but usually
it's for a year two years three years
whatever it is gives you time to develop
and sell your products we don't have
anyone who says okay Le your budget's
$25 million here's $75 million that'll
cover you for the next three years just
doesn't work that way in my world we're
Scrappy scraping by in the trenches
every single day trying to raise the
money from foundations from wealthy
individuals uh small donors big donors
online campaigns Partnerships corporate
support you know that's we're a sales
organization that's what everyone else
in the organization is is is doing is
trying to make sure we have the
resources to run this big gorilla that
we're
managing incredible and so how do you
even deal with the situation like that
where you don't have an opportunity like
you the one you presented how as an
organization or as a leader of an
organization how do you innovatively
deal with a situation like that because
you must have some you must have to be
extra Innovative and extra creative to
be able to deal with this you don't have
the luxury of just saying yeah you know
we're just going to make even more
profit out of this so obviously we're
going to be spending all this money
so okay it's a great question actually I
don't think I've ever been asked it in
that way so thank you for that so look
let's say like this we take great pride
in trying to fundraise from people only
once a year okay and so what are you
doing the organization when
opportunities Ares and we've had for
over the years we've been we've had
enough money in the bank that we wanted
to take some chances either we could or
we could go to seon who we hadn't asked
for money and said would you consider
adding something on we want to try X Y
or Z however in the last few years first
with Co and now with this Russia thing
Ukraine let's give let's call Ukraine
thing let's give the ukrainians the um
know the smile sure
um we made decision in each of the last
three years that we would go out to our
donor base a second time and say to them
we have a unique opportunity of course
you then get grumbles from some people
who say wow that seems to be on RAR
footing you know you're you what are you
now an emergency Organization no but the
last three years have been really
unprecedented you had two years of covid
so let me give an example what I mean
from Co wette on March 10th 2020 was
collecting around 10,000 cooked meals a
day within one month hotels were closed
corporate cafeterias were closed tourism
was closed restaurants were closed there
were no events we were almost down to
zero we made a decision to go to our
donor and say to them leet is going to
buy food we don't buy food but we're
going to buy food now because we think
we've created the Goodwill with our
donor base and our agencies need our
help and you know what we spent about $8
million in 2020 and 2021 buying meals
from suppliers who normally give us food
for free and so yeah not what Lea does
that desperate times call for desperate
measures
and again I'm really hoping that
2023 things will just get back to normal
stock market will go back to where I
hope it will be uh inflation will Tamp
down because that impacts us and of
course impacts the people that we serve
but I really want a regular year where
fundraising just goes like it's supposed
to go and and then we don't have to go
back to people and say because you hate
you hate being a that kind of a fun
raiser that you're always in an
emergency we've always we've had
basically 17 18 years where you know we
H we didn't our bird rate was sufficient
the money we had was sufficient to put
us through what we needed to do to make
our payroll and so it would be nice to
go back to that Joseph it's such a such
a unique organization and I love the
longevity and the marathon type into the
journey and
then I you can just tell how passionate
you are about about what you're and and
the impact that you're making and so I
really appreciate you coming on to this
show and spending these 20 minutes with
me 20 short minutes that we can't
possibly ENC caply everything there is
about about Le or your journey but but
at least leaving with some inspiration
about H what it's like uh providing so
many millions of meals to so many
millions of people I think it's just
such a such a it's it's you know one of
those times where you say those numbers
and you say wow you know there every
number within those Millions is a person
who is eating who's actually getting you
know in maso's pyramid a foundation for
what they need in order to to be a human
in this world and so it's um it's really
an honor for me to be speaking to you
now and to to get that inspiration and
to share it with others and so thank you
very very much for the time and the
energy wishing you an amazing shat in
2023 that where you'll be able to
operate as normal which is sounds like a
not not a trivial wish but definitely an
important
whatever normal is well thank you very
much for the opportunity feel honored to
do the work that I'm doing and of course
anyone watching this podcast who wants
to come volunteer for leet check out our
website L
k.org um Joseph l.org happy to hear from
anyone questions
comments amazing appreciate thank you
Joseph